Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to talk about OpenAI’s
amazing image generator AI, DALL-E 2,
and you will see that it can do two things
that perhaps not many of you have heard of.
So, what is DALL-E 2? This is a diffusion-based AI
model, which means that it starts out from noise,
and gradually changes it to become a beautiful
image like this one. The image can be anything,
so much so that we can enter a piece of text,
and magically, out comes an image that fits
this description. It would be hard to overstate
how transformative this will be to digital art.
Imagine that you could now illustrate any
novel…and not only that, but it wouldn’t even need
any additional work for you
to write up the text prompts.
Just take excerpts from the
novel, and there we go. Wow.
And, if you feel like adding crazy prompts, as
you see, it won’t complain about that either. But,
it can do even more. For instance, if
we have an image that we really like,
variant generation is also possible. This means
that we can provide it an input image, it tries
to understand what it depicts, and create several
versions of it. And it does that spectacularly.
But, that’s not the only little-known
feature is does, it also two other amazing
things. One is image inpainting. What is that?
Inpainting means that we take an input image
or video, cut out an undesirable part, and let
an algorithm fill in the holes with data that
makes sense given the context of this image. Now,
previous techniques were already capable of this,
but I am very excited to see what DALL-E 2 can do
with this problem, because we know that it has a
really detailed understanding of the world around
us. So, can it use its knowledge of the world to
create high-quality inpaintings? Oh boy, you will
see in a moment that it can do it incredibly well.
Let’s give it a try. Oh yes, we can delete this
squirrel, and here comes the key: oh my! Remember
that I said that inpainting techniques fill
in the holes given the context of the image.
But DALL-E 2 does something even better! It fills
in the image with any context we can think of.
Let’s try that! How? Well, this image is
ridiculous - squirrels are known not to be
able to operate computers, so, let’s add a hippo
instead. And there we go! Much better. Loving it.
Now let’s push it to the limits
through 5 outstanding examples!
One. The ladybug. Here is a
photo, but, look. Unfortunately,
some parts of the photo are out of focus. Oh
yes, how about deleting those parts, and have
them inpainted with DALL-E 2? Could that work? It
knows that this is a ladybug after all. Let’s see.
Wow. That is much sharper and fits the
image really well. I would have to look
for quite a bit to find out the trickery. What
about you? Let me know in the comments below! So
this is fantastic. But you know what is even
more fantastic? Now hold on to your papers,
because it can also do not only image
inpainting, but image outpainting!
What is that? Well, two. Ever wondered what might
be outside of this frame? Well, let’s ask DALL-E
2 and…that is insanity. It is really doing it. And
we can just zoom out and out and out and it feels
like it never stops. And it just gets crazier
over time. If a human would have made this,
I would say that human is very creative. But
this was done by a machine. Is that a hint of
creativity in a machine? Food for thought.
I love this one. What a time to be alive!
Three, of course, we need to do that to the
Mona Lisa too. What could be outside the frame?
Ah, I see! This is a more modern take on
the old classic. Working at the office while
everyone else is enjoying life. Note that
once again, a prompt was used to generate
the theme of the outpainting here. These are
the prompts that were used for this example.
And, these are so good, let’s do a
couple more. Four. Zooming out from
a house in the middle of a lush field to
this. Very artistic. And it turns out,
wow…that we are on a floating island in
the middle of the universe…with a twist.
And, last, but not least. Five, the Last Supper.
But this time, let’s not zoom out, but let’s try
to answer one of history’s big questions: and that
is, what might be going on in the adjacent rooms.
Look. I love it. And I wonder what DALL-E
3 will be capable of? Remember, the DALL-E
2 version came out just about a year after the
first version, and it was leaps and bounds better.
And the competition is also coming, Google
already has their Imagen and Parti AI’s,
and even that is just scratching the surface. As
you see, the pace of progress in AI research is
absolutely incredible. These tools are going
to transform the world around us as we know it,
especially now that OpenAI is aiming to deploy
this AI to no less than 1 million people in the
near future. How cool is that! Democratizing
art creation for all of us. Soon. Bravo!
So, does this get your mind going? Do you have
any thoughts as to what DALL-E 3 could do?
Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!